nous sommes au port on est sur le quai
du port ouest et face à moi la nylose le
une frégate de la marine nationale
oui alors les caviste qui sont derrière
moi en fait sont là pour faire un
tournage d'un petit film dans le cadre
de plusieurs épisodes je l'espère qui
s'appelle j'irai tirer près de chez vous
et le but du jeu c'est de faire un
tournage absolument
inutile mais original
l'idée c'est justement de sortir de des
rails du lieu commun et de pouvoir
se montrer et démontrer quelque chose à
l'extérieur sur un lieu qui est tout à
fait anachronique mais c'est celui-ci
qui va attirer justement le regard du
futur licencié ou le regard de ceux qui
s'intéressent un petit peu de plus près
à nous
aujourd'hui une image elle est elle est
planétaire avec avec internet avec
Youtube etc on a on a évidemment une une
vision qui est planétaire on sait
qu'aujourd'hui lorsque les Canadiens
sortent un petit film on l'a
automatiquement d'ailleurs que Google
sur sur notre bonne paye donc voilà tout
se sait en temps réel aujourd'hui
déjà fêter un petit peu le départ du
commandant en second de la nivause yens
Soulard parce que c'est un petit peu un
cadeau de départ qui vous fait là et
puis je souhaite aussi initier d'autres
épisodes d'autres lieux de tournage
comme ça l'acronique et puis c'est aussi
un moyen de montrer que la canari
lyonnaise elle est toujours innovante
pas seulement à travers sa technologie
d'arbitrage pas seulement à travers son
logiciel de compétition pas seulement à
travers ces résultats en compétition
mais aussi sur le regard général sur
l'intelligence générale de la cadrer
lyonnaise